if you're in your 20s watch this video
22 to 30 should be experimenting do
random [__] go skateboard go cook go try
flip life everybody's got so much
pressure to like have it figured out
when they come out of school and that's
the biggest mistake that people make
like it's time to be real in real life
and all that [__] it's [__] stupid
maybe you're the best surfer in the
world maybe you're the best caviar
[__] Chef on the planet I ran a
[__] liquor
[Music]
store my [__] mind we're starting a
vlog about wine in 2006 but then I
tasted something and it changed my
[__] life it's no different than
kissing a bunch of frogs until you find
your prince the people that will cast
judgment on someone who's still trying
to explore are people who themselves
settled without exploring your parents
these are your best friends these are
your siblings they're not intending to
be mean tear you down stop you conform
you into settling like they did but
that's exactly what they're doing
Society is incredibly subconsciously
interested in you conforming don't